I think that like anything else in life
every coin has two sides to it and i
think that the good thing about more and
more food on television is that we're
now in a country where good ingredients
and good cooking and good recipes are
not a foreign concept to people people
are much much more aware of the role
that food can play at the table and I
think that young people watch the Food
Network it last time I checked it's
rated G most of the stories have a happy
ending and you know I think that the the
to the degree that Julia Child was able
to make an impact on a whole generation
of people when she was the only game in
town I think the food network is believe
it or not having an even bigger impact
on even more people and so I think that
from a standpoint of being a
restaurateur it's a good thing because
more and more people are interested in
and follow what's happening in the food
scene the other side of the coin is that
the restaurant business is not a sitcom
and it's not a reality TV show it's it's
a real day-to-day persistent journey
about delivering pleasure for other
people and it's a very very humble
pursuit and I think that the the part of
the TV aspect of food that it may be
less helpful is that what plays well on
TV is sometimes brashness as opposed to
humility serving other people as a
humble act it's the belief that if I do
something for you that's going to make
me feel better sometimes that's not
what's portrayed on TV it's you know
cursing and tattoos and brashness which
is fine but that's not really what the
pleasure of table is all about
I think we'll see some changes and I
think we always have one of the things
that's amazing about my industry is that
there's there's just this incredible
sense that there's always going to be a
tomorrow and you know I've now been in
business long enough to have seen for
pretty serious recessions and
fortunately so far to have survived them
all but it's it's like a mean nasty wind
that blows a heck of a lot of the leaves
off the trees what I find amazing about
my colleagues there's this never say die
entrepreneurial spirit and behind every
leaf that falls off there's a new bud
that that that you know blooms and
blossoms what's fascinating is to see
what each recession generates in terms
of the next generation of restaurants
you know i'll never forget all the way
back in 1991 1992 when there was a
recession connected with the Gulf War
everybody was saying back then this is
the end of fine dining which was totally
not true there was a period during which
people were eating more casually but we
have long since passed the point as a
country where people are not going to go
backwards in terms of the quality of
what they eat no one's going to say oh
it's a recession now I want to eat food
that doesn't taste good what they might
say is ok I don't want to spend as much
money or I don't have as much time or i
don't want to pay extra for all the
trappings of cushy chairs and beautiful
art on the walls and that type of thing
does come and go the restaurant that
will be opening this fall which will be
called maialino based on my love for
Rome is without question a recession
baby it's going to be a restaurant that
that I would hope that people could
frequent even in a recession that won't
put it out of business you know during a
good economy but what's what I also find
fascinating blue smoke which is our
barbecue restaurant that has thrived
throughout this over
session was born just a handful of
months after 911 and it was born in a
recession 2002 and sometimes the
restaurants that the buds the blossoms
that that come to life during a
recession are some of the most
long-lived as a result of that you know
a trattoria in Rome there are thousands
of them and nobody goes there to find
cutting edge nobody goes there only for
special occasions what distinguishes one
trattoria from the next is the one that
you go to the most frequently so their
restaurants that are created really for
the purpose of allowing people to be
with people in to break bread without a
lot of the trappings without paying
extra money for the fancy plates and the
expensive furnishings in the restaurant
and it's really more about the soul of
eating well than it is of the refined
restaurant experience I don't believe
that the refined restaurant experience
ever thrives as much in a deep recession
but I also believe that there's always
going to be a place you know for a
restaurant that is that just gives you
that extra sense that you took a trip
somewhere we have a restaurant eleven
madison park that just got four stars
from the new york times and by all by
all rights it should not be doing well
in a recession and it's doing better now
you